-Higgins, the craziest thing
happened to me this morning.
-What?
-I was walking to work,
and I was walking, probably
around 29th street.
I just started --
[ Phone ringing ]
The red phone's ringing.
Sorry.
Someone's trying
to FaceTime me.
[ Phone ringing ]
It's Dwayne Johnson.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Should I -- Should I pick up?
-Got to pick up.
-Dwayne?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hey there, buddy.
-[ Laughs ]
What's up, buddy?
-Oh, man.
Hey, look, Jimmy.
I know you're right in the
middle of shooting your show
and -- hey, what's up audience?
How you guys doing?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah.
-Dude, I know you're
right in the middle
of shooting your show,
but I just got some news.
I'm here working out in
The Iron Paradise, too.
But I just got some news.
It's critical news, and I just
had to share it with you.
-What's up?
-All right.
Well, I was just told that
the Christmas gift I got you
last month, finally arrived
and it's there in your studio.
It's right behind the curtain,
and I think you should
look at it.
-Where is it?
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yeah. Uh...
I have no idea --
What is it?
-Well, that is a 250-pound rock
from "The Rock."
-Hey, I get it.
Wow.
-Okay, but that's not
just the good news.
All right. You're thinking,
"Wow, dreams come true."
But hold on a second.
-I wasn't thinking that at all.
-That rock comes from my NBC hit
show called "The Titan Games,"
where we have very
inspiring people
doing really epic, incredibly
athletic competitions
and competitive events
on television.
The greatest you've ever seen.
-Yeah.
-Now, I thought since that rock
weighs 250 pounds
and well -- that one does --
I weigh 260.
But who's counting?
-Clearly you are.
You're the one who said it.
-You have sent over
250 e-mails, 250 texts,
250 voicemails talking about
how you want to get
in the best shape
of your life in 2019.
I thought, "You know what?
I got an idea."
Christmas gift would drop
from "Dwayntaclaus."
So, I think right here --
-"Dwayntaclaus."
-Right now on your show,
you take
"The Titan Games" challenge.
-No, I don't want to.
Not right now.
No, no. Dwayne.
I love "Titan Games."
I love the show, and thank you
for thinking of me,
but it's not gonna happen.
I cannot --
I cannot move a 250-pound rock.
[ Audience "Aw"s ]
-Wait a second. Wait a minute.
Wait a minute. Wait.
All you got to do, dude --
all you got to do --
I want you take
that 250 pound --
-No, I don't know.
-I just want you to drag it
across the studio.
You can do it.
I think you can do it,
the world thinks you can do it,
and the audience thinks
you can do it.
Jimmy. Jimmy. Jimmy.
[ Crowd chants "Jimmy" ]
-So embarrassing.
♪♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Come on, dude.
Yes.
Put your muscles into it.
Put your glutes into it.
-Oh!
-Oh, man.
-Come on, Jimmy.
Come on, Jimmy.
Jimmy. Jimmy. Jimmy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, man.
-Hey, you know what, dude?
You know what, Jimmy.
-Yeah.
-I am so sorry. You know,
I love and respect you man.
I didn't mean to put you on the
spot, but -- you know what?
You need a little bit of help.
My man Higgins, Tariq,
please come and help Jimmy
drag that rock.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You get in there first.
♪♪
-Grab the chain.
-What?
-Grab the -- no, no.
The chain!
-Oh, like that?
-What's wrong with you?
One, two, three.
-You got it, boys.
-Let's go.
-That was easy, we did it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
That was easy.
-Hey, buddy.
-That's how it's done.
-That was it.
That was it, right there.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Dwayne...
Dwayne, we did it, buddy.
Uh, now -- now what -- now what
do I do with this thing?
[ Light laughter ]
-Oh, uh, you know what?
I have no idea. It's up to you.
Merry Christmas.
Love you brother.
Bye.
-Oh, my God.
A rock -- A 250-pound rock
from "The Rock."
Dwayne Johnson, everybody.
Love that guy.
Check out "The Titan Games"
Thursdays at 8:00 P.M. on NBC.